good morning gamers that's right
sven is here it's a beautiful day and
we're gonna play minecraft how did i
become a minecraft channel
and everyone is on board with it if this
video gets a million likes
we're gonna make it minecraft month no
no no i'm kidding or am i okay so first
of all we have a lot of stuff to do
today
aren't we swen i i broke my ankle sven
coming down from there
i've been getting a lot of tips from you
guys from on the reddit and one of them
was how do you change to a swedish
banner flag
so we're gonna make that because i made
a lot of epic upgrades to the house
it's not epics fan he's so excited he's
leaving me look at that that's beautiful
his friend hey he doesn't even want to
look at me i accidentally killed his
boat cow's friend he's like i'm not
making eye contact with you
i'm sorry he had to die right sven
it's fenugreek okay so we're going to
make the banner there's one thing i want
to do first
because as you can see the cows have
gotten
their farm shot up shut up
god
[Music]
there's always something else to do in
this game god damn it
uh also this series got a shout out from
the god of minecraft notch himself
thank you not for watching okay i'm done
i'm done okay you get gamers get to eat
now here you go
here you go you get to eat you get to
eat you all get wheat you all get
weak just calm down i know it's very
look they have plenty of space look how
much they're moving
if they had if they didn't have space
they wouldn't be moving am i right
gamers
oh my god the game froze what happened
[Laughter]
no no oh i almost let them out okay so i
have this new system
double gate gamers get out of the way
cow
double game okay gamers
you're free you're free
be free oh my god
oh my god there's so many of you
look there's plenty of space i'm so
generous
now where were the ones i let out i want
to kill them look at that
beautiful beautiful isn't that beautiful
jurgen
you're good i'm speaking to you hello
what are you doing oh god okay i'll kill
the mom
okay so there is actually a reason i did
all that
which we'll get to in a second i just
need to organize my inventory oh wow
does it look good felix
and i also built uh a fence so sven
can't die from the lava don't worry
gamer
if sven dies this playthrough is over
okay so the reason why we need it's
because apparently
this is redstone which activates stuff
so if i happen to put down a dynamite it
would activate the dynamite
and therefore my house would blow up
which is not good in minecraft
generally you want to avoid blowing up
your house that's a pro tip from a
veteran gamer you guys are
welcome if we cut the sheep we can make
wool which we can make i'm like doing
the swedish accent unironically at this
point
chop ship ship ship ship ship ship ship
ship ship
chip chimp church come on you will all
ship ships
i don't care what peter says i don't
care you will ship
you win ship started
oh god the leg oh god the leg
oh god the leg this is what you created
pizza
if i can't kill them overpopulation will
happen
don't escape no no one escapes
if anyone else tries it that's what i
thought okay gamers
now we have wool what the frick are you
doing
that's what you get and that same thing
will happen to you one day if you ever
make it out of there which you won't by
the way
you're doomed there for eternity that's
right
let's also make sure we pay our respects
okay okay gamers okay so now
we have a freak ton of wool but we need
to dye it obviously i think you use
flowers to die so we need yeah we need
blue and
red yellow obviously and i think i want
to make the carpet
black which you get from why am i
talking unironically about this and why
are you unironically like
i think you get the black from the
squids which i will kill now
watch me gamers do you swim faster next
to dolphins
i don't realize that there used to be a
million squids here what the frick
stupid fish ruined my life did you get
fish
show me where the squids are what are
you doing sven
god damn it all right fine
fine you can take over why are you not
dead
go away i will freak you
i'll freak a skeleton you have phones i
like it
oh yeah and i caught a dolphin i
remember is it still here
what the dolphin escaped it was down
here i swear
what the hell where did the dolphin
escape to
why my dolphin not working lol okay
gamers
this is an epic moment there's an epic
moment uh-huh he agrees
hello there fellow tradesmen what are
you selling
whoa i need those
god don't spit i think i need this right
but they're so expensive
i'm thinking i'm thinking okay how much
do they cost
a bucket of tropical fish dude i can get
a tropical fish
i could get a tropical fish be right
back
damn it i can't play this game for two
seconds without getting distracted
i have other stuff planned this episode
it wasn't supposed to go this way
oh god get the money get the money i
feel like i just ran into the ice cream
truck or something i'm gonna get a
goddamn bucket
of fish and it's gonna be awesome a
bucket of fish bucket a fish bucket of
fish bucket of fish bucket of fish
come on bucket of fish oh he's still
here thank god i gotta pee so bad
red bucket of fish is waiting all right
bucket of fish man
i'm sinking ass i'm talking it's really
annoying
i can heat cheat gravity i get two
bucket of fishes
i'll get these because i know i can do
something with them two bucket of fish
and now comes the best part the
murdering
that's right give me back my money oh
god they're spitting stop it
stop it i didn't do anything i'm
innocent i'm 100 innocent
what you just witnessed was he hacked
your eyes
all right god damn it why would you spit
on me yet
why would you spit on me i spit on you i
took
filthy collections i spit on you and
your mother
jurgen would never spit on me okay so
we're gonna
i'm looking for squids that's why i came
here
stupid squiddy where are you
i will find you squids whoa what is this
whoa this is literally in my house and
i've never seen it
what is this what is this okay i'm
drowning
oh god i keep getting distracted we were
supposed to make a swedish banner god
damn it
why is this in my backyard who put this
here i've never seen these blocks before
hello well there's people down there ah
water people why you live there however
never noticed this back off water people
[Music]
all right water people got pooped on is
there a chest down here or something
there's a chest down here ah and it's
garbage although there is a treasure map
am i actually full again i don't need
that
what was i doing the flag felix okay
fine we'll do the flag
all right you're can you come in with me
we're gonna pick flowers
it's picking flowers with my best bro
jurgen time all right i need you to
why can't i go oh he's on the leash
i'm sorry here again
i was like why is it not working there
you go
now we can go oh my god nothing like
picking flowers with your best bro ain't
it
okay blue as well perfect
absolutely epic if we could find red as
well that'd be
oh yeah oh yeah yeah again today is our
day
it's gaming week possibly gaming month
year again think about that
i think minecraft is probably the only
game where i would actually enjoy
picking flowers
but it's so nice isn't it
you roll with everything don't ever look
at jurgen again okay we got plenty of
red time this is perfect
stop stop in the name of law you don't
want to go to my prison i did you favor
oh it's enderman oh it's
no damn it i know i'm supposed to kill
them because
of the ender dragon but that's all i
know the pearls or something
anyway i think we have our stuff we'll
head back
it's gaming week i thought they looked
cool okay
they're like glowy and stuff it's epic
carpet
right so how do we okay just like that
cool we're making the die
youtube demonetization bot just picked
up me saying the bad word
okay cool so now we have red wall this
is epic do i know how many i need
absolutely not we'll just go by the flow
bing bam boom bing bang bang bing bong
okay
boom next we make the bender okay so i
have to follow the tutorial you guys
made first
we make banner and it has to be blue
so we need six of the blue light blue no
dark blue freak it i need three more
i have two more frick it
oh yeah the reason i bought the shell is
because i know you can combine it with
heart of the sea
that's all i know literally all i know
oh yeah these can make uh blue dye
perfect
ah that's not a design flaw that's a
feature
thank you one two three
epic gamer can't you see i make me
a blue flaggy epic
okay so we do one two three one two
three
and then stick bam we got ourselves a
banner
now we have to do ruling
what is it called ruling yes looming
okay we need ship chop your horse nope
oh loom i told you loom
okay we can loom here this will be
looming station
very epic i need to see well to do
looming
epic we need the yellow dye okay okay
okay yellow dye
[Laughter]
we got it all gamers swedish flag time
so we put
this here and we put this here and we
click
and bam bing bing bong bing bong
go away ugly banner how do i ugly with
banner go away
shush sure spender uh
oh there it is okay it's gone and it's
gone and boom
oh that's epic i love it
that's cool oh god i should have gone
with
oh i should have done yellow here that
oh my god i gotta look
all right gamers no i did not just do
wool with a diamond pickaxe don't worry
about it you guys have to worry about
every detail
whatever i use a shovel bing bong bing
bing bong
damn this looks good damn that looks
good
okay all right
[Music]
i think we should do blue here actually
this is what minecraft is all about
color coordinating something
only gamers will understand
bambam boom yeah it's gotta be like that
gamers
we gotta make the bed match of course
and sven's sitting pad
throw my old bed in the fire no big deal
oh man dark wood bed
that might be epic all right there it is
i love how when you hold it it's so tiny
and then bam
beautiful let's not forget about sven's
sitting cushion
beam bomb cute if someone would leave
the boat
you could actually enjoy it so the
reason i kept this is because it's a
bjjrk and it's a very swedish famous
tree i think
or maybe not i think every country has a
feeling okay well whatever
gamer all right i forgot about my bucket
of fish
[Music]
there's too much happening in this game
i can't keep up where should i keep my
bucket of fish
maybe here in the little pond there you
go bucket of fish
all right i'll find a better use for you
later oh god don't tell me this runs out
in the water
no it doesn't i don't i don't trust you
guys
now now now now buck now tropical
tropical tropical tropical tropical no i
punched the fish i'm so sorry
where did the other one go come back
here you tropical
son of a snake i pay good money for you
fish
i will do with you as i please all right
i want you'll go here for now okay so if
you thought that was it
that was not it okay we have many epic
things to do because
i am so obsessed jesus christ
they're antagonizing they set up a trap
yo go to sleep go to sleep go to sleep
it's really cool easter egg
just click on the bed just click on the
bed ha ha he did it idiot a pig on top
okay so i may i figured out since you
guys told me
that there's eight blocks in the nether
round in irl
that i can make a portal to new places
that i want to go to
i know iq 5000. as long as i don't get
attack here
we should be all right so we have this
portal which goes to
epic place hello thanks for welcoming me
so i found this city i never explored it
yet but it looks so cool they got like
houses in the mountains and
they are all depressed it's awesome
they're just like me we're totally
fitting in hello
what okay hippity hoppity your money is
my property as we say in sweden
this is why they're depressed everyone's
taking their stuff i didn't do anything
i swear
i didn't do anything all right what else
more money
it's poor people oh poor people don't
worry if you're mad ab
if you're mad at me uh oh they have
jurgens
is there no one to trade here there's
really then there's no reason for me to
build that portal thing that i spent so
long on
hello is there anyone that want to trade
they're all just
a bunch of poor people oh my god it's a
tight oh god they're so creepy dude
notch would not have come up with those
i'm not saying i don't like them
all i'm saying is notch would not have
made them all right what about the ones
in the mountain maybe that's where the
epic one is
do you guys do anything any day all day
[Music]
hopefully hey look it's a cat do i have
the bucket i don't have the bucket all
right
you win this time cat you win this town
look how cute they designed it
that one's have a hat maybe that one can
train hello hat man
ow broke my leg it's fine hat man
hat man trades wait i have so much wheat
i'm gonna be rich
okay the portal was worth it there's one
thing i thought about
because i always have to look for them
right is it mean if i
lock them in so i don't have to look for
them all the time right
okay cool so now i'll find him easier
more easily perfect you just stay there
epic all right uh let's check the top
hippity hop
video whoa all right it's better not be
a trap
okay flowers for year again it's
actually a nice house like
i would like to live here maybe we'll
we'll immigrate with jurgen one day
to a new place all right we're going to
sleep because uh there's another thing
around here
that i have never seen before and that
is
my gamers we'll get to it in a sec let's
go oh it's a is that a church
does that mean that there's a god of
minecraft of course there is
notch must be inside here nochi
hello what is this brewing stan
what the freaky they got colored glass
what they got torches
this is awesome this city is cool i like
this city
oh epic i wanna i wanna
lock him in as well actually why don't i
just dig underneath him
no stop don't escape there you go
enjoy enjoy the whole let's just put
this here so we find you
enjoy the whole have fun i'll trade with
you later
i'll let you out if you trade with me
hippity hop buddy hello jurgens
here you go have apple there you go
enjoy
see they have a road and stuff it's
awesome as gamers know
whenever there's a pretty utopia there
are other people
that want to take part of it
where is it there it is see they have
the
this is i never seen this but it's an
enemy camp
look at them so we're gonna go absolute
sicko mode right now i'm gonna set up a
little uh
defense maybe here
oh god they're coming don't shoot
don't shoot you will never get past my
defense
how can you shoot backwards oh they keep
coming
okay easy there's a lot more of them
though
come on gamers that guy just tried to
360.
work i'm gonna kill them all
i don't care what it takes
wow you're all gonna die chomp chomp
chomp
chomp chomp
[Music]
if you guys get along then maybe you can
kill me
oh yeah
should we blow it up do i i have tnt
i'm tempted to just go back and get to
tnt
oh god there's more
this must be the leader wow
where are you from
dude he dropped the crossbow i never had
this before look at me
oh i hear more of them i think they
respawn
okay we better we better advance our way
inside
all right pirates bring your a game
or your b game actually no think
no think just kill bye
oh whoa bottle of enchanting what is
that
okay i'll take a game oh damn they all
respawn
oopsie i think they're angry can i blow
up their place though i legit wanna
oh
time to bounce later gamer
ah home sweden home okay so
i have all this rotten flesh i knew i
knew saving up all this useless stuff
was gonna be worth it
oh man i just realized i googled
how to make dynamite fbi is going to
find me guys
oopsie gun powder which i have oh god
oh my god oh my god
no wonder my game is lagging all right
i just need to do a dynamite test so i
think if i remember
you could use redstone as like a fuse
uh do i lit it or no
hmm
maybe i can is it one of these
the torch and i hit it with the torch
oh yep
okay
[Music]
wait what what is happening
raid i think i read a comment about this
i didn't think it would happen oh god
guys we're raided
what is happening is it hard i think
people said it was hard
you guys will help me right oh they're
all freaking out they don't want to
trade with me now
oh frick i'm not ready for this i'm
ready to blow up
oh there they are there they are oh wow
stone guy is
killing it dick don't worry guys don't
worry i protection
oh sorry i almost shot him
kill the hat man get out of the bed
did it wait what it continues
oh god charge my crossbows oh god they
mean business
chief says oh my god dude
they got axe people oh my god oh my god
i'm dead
there's only one way out this is not
even my city
oh god i swear i had so much food
oh god the iron golem is not helping
oh thank god i protected them
yeah what'd i say you thought it was
cruel
bring it oh god that dudes a lot of
damage
it's a leader
bring it
two remaining oh thank god the baby
made it
i'll barricade him so no one can kill
the child
oh my god he's alive thank god all right
let me buy the last one
oh god it's another raid i can't deal
with this
oh we're gonna have to get the big guns
out oh they're coming from the other
side
holy freaky mickey what is that
oh it's gonna have to go boom
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa relax
i'm not i didn't sign up for this i did
not sign up for this i did not sign up
for this this is not my city this is not
my battle
no one said anything about giant
freaking bulldozers
just want to eat i just want to eat wow
[Music]
oh he shot this one wow
come on raiders oh it's only the
bulldozer left oh god how how how how
how okay range range battle
oh god it sees me
i'm sorry sorry party
oh god it's got a lot of help
and i'm gamers oh
oh this is bad you're getting with audio
i'm out of arrows freaky okay i have a
gamer plan i have a game
plan
oh god
oh gamer oh
wow you're really angry aren't you
[Music]
[Applause]
ah oh my god
oh oh my god
oh
oh in chalk
oh it died oh god it keeps going i can't
do more
dude they got wizards and stuff this
time i'm sorry wizards
oh god am i actually gonna die how long
does this last
how do i care poison
oh my god this is the most intense
battle i have ever done in my life
no damn it
why am i here oh because i slept in the
bed oh my god i'm an idiot
or a genius question mark freaking one
shot at me dude
oh my god that's where it went
oh
no are you kidding me
these freakers are cr they're crazy they
one-shot you
go go go go go oh he went through two
that's
this is phenomenal
are you kidding me my stuff is right
there
jesus christ
[Music]
luckily i do remember the way home it's
just very far
oh boy what a day it's not over yet the
battle is still on
all right god i have to make so much new
stuff
oh god if only the pigs could help me
okay they should be over there oh my god
they are
look at that butt dude okay maybe i can
push him off
oh get off you kidding me
and i respawn here because i forgot to
sleep
oh my god yes
that's the best thing that could ever
happen
oh no i'm so out of luck dude
he's blowing up my bridge
i want my stuff back
yes
no another i can't do another i'm done
how long this is keep going
oh my god what they're riding them now
they really want they really want blood
i'll give them that this is a bit more
than i bargained for
jesus lord
it's over anakin i have the high ground
don't do it we can be friends
don't shoot
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
oh god
okay if i stand really low
he shoots himself yes
yes gaming i did it i did it
[Music]
oh it's free you're free to go you're
free to live
you're free to you're free i saved your
people
the child oh no
well jurgen is jurgens are okay
[Music]
what the freak is this
have fun in hell what the freak
and we're back home very
epic that's it for me for now smash like
for more minecraft and i see you guys
next time bye
what you never played two for simulator
you know it's fun right i'm not supposed
to give my opinion
but give it a try and then you can tell
me if it's good or not
not convinced yet okay i'll cut you a
deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
you